this chapter is called new world
revelation and the fluff you all there
in the last chapter a few other groups
that has a sort of distinctively
American start you know they're not
coming over like the Lutheran's are or
the Presbyterians from someplace else
they're not you know developing
something out of that beginnings the way
the Puritans between the
Congregationalists these were
denominations that are distinctively
American now they they hit the spread
worldwide to a certain extent by mission
work especially the one that we're going
to look at here the latter-day saints
they're a growing organization if i
remember right looking at the latest
religious figures there the fourth of
the fifth largest denomination in the
united states they have a pretty
significant worldwide presence most of
them are concentrated in one single
church there are a few others smaller
latter-day saints churches that we're
going to talk about in other chapters
today we're looking at the origin of
these guys so you might be mentioning
just in passing burns over district in
New York and that's kind of interest to
us because we're here in New York so the
birch / district is upstate it wouldn't
include right here this has a kind of
weird stance right are we upstate right
now now for people from the city we are
right what do people from say oneonta
think about about this area re upstate
no and so we're a no variable status the
Upstate area the the real Upstate area
got to be called the burnt over district
not because there were a lot of prairie
fires or anything like that but because
there were all these revivals people
would get you know worked up and convert
and then you know we saw with revivals
there's kind of an avid flow with it and
in these revivals people would start
arguing about things they didn't just
you know come to meet Jesus or have a
good time some of them some people
actually want to revive us for
entertainment purposes because sometimes
it was the only you know getting
together in town but a lot of people
started arguing about topics in
and you guys know how it is one of the
reasons why they tell you not to engage
in a lot of arguments at the dinner
table about religion is because people
can get so upset about it and it's
something where people have very fixed
stances so this guy Joseph Smith who is
going to be the founder of this new
organization he's growing up in this
setting where there's already a lot of
intense religious debate yeah and like a
book points out there there's some other
things that he's involved in as well
some you know folk practices and
divination he is it's interesting
because we read the book of Mormon which
you can find here like your book points
out in marriott hotels because they're
owned by the latter day soon you'll find
that a lot of the controversies of the
time or actually him in one way or
another in that book like Joseph Smith
we had a lot of those things in mind as
he's he's carrying out what he calls a
work of translation so this guy Joseph
Smith says that he has this part of his
religious experience that he has
revelations or a vision and this starts
when he is like a book points out 14 so
in 1820 he says the father and the son
appear to him and quashing him against
joining any of the denominations that
are out there at the time the
denominations are arguing with each
other are you know are the Presbyterians
writer the Lutheran's writer the
congregation Lester in three years later
he goes into a trance he says that the
angel Moroni appears to him virani is
the survivor of one of the groups that
we're going to see collective out of the
Book of Mormon this is an ancient
American people the Senate from the
Hebrews that were destroyed by a rival
tribe his father Mormon and trusted him
with a sacred book this is where we get
the name of the book of mormon from so
it's Maroni Mormon his father and he
tells Joseph Smith all of his history
recorded on these golden tablets that
are buried under a hill and this is
going to be really central for the
latter-day saints he also tells him that
there's these two stones of the room and
and footmen and in the ink in the
ancient Jewish Scriptures these are
actually the stones at the the juditha
Jewish temple the priests would use to
cast lots to try to consult what God
wanted from them he sees them as being
sort of a translating device so later on
he gets the plates in another vision and
now he starts his career as translating
he's having these visions now we're
starting a career as translating these
golden plains or tablets and that's what
the Book of Mormon is going to come from
he brings in this guy Oliver Cowdery
another important name we're going to
see a few other people being really
central to this new movement and he and
powdery together receive a new
revelation announcing the restoration of
the erotic priesthood now if you if
you're wondering what is that because
going to her do that before erin was
Moses his brother an errand would sort
of set aside to be a priest so there's
this entire priesthood that's supposed
to be descended from Aaron and you're
going to see this theme over and over
again with the latter-day saints of a
restoration on something that was
previously there and now has to be
reconstituted he also talks about
baptism under a new and everlasting
covenant and your book at this point
starts talking about three different
elements that are coming together that
that create a here's use a constant
question that people
about latter-day saints are they
Christians are either Christians and the
answer is yes and no from their own
perspective they're sort of like the
culmination of Christianity but for a
lot of Christian denominations they're
not Christian why well they've got some
extra things for most Christians what
you call the Canon of Scripture meaning
the books that are considered to be
authorized revelation they added about
where the book of Revelation in the New
Testament right so if you're adding in a
new book that's going to be unsettling
to many people if you're adding it in
one new book why not yet in multiple new
blogs why not have anybody say that
something fits a man so that's going to
be one reason why a lot of Christians
are going to reject them as Christians
your book talks about three elements
prophet church and description so that
who's the Prophet Joseph Smith what's
the church the people who will begin
following him and the scripture would be
the Book of Mormon so let's look at the
book summary of the book of mormon story
that it tells is though this hebrew
patriot lady leaves jerusalem just
before the babylonian conquest this may
not mean that much to you but the
Babylonian conquest is something really
trot the attic for for the Jewish people
if you read the Old Testament so you
over and over again the cycle of God say
is the Jews and then the Jews can screw
around and do the wrong things and then
God punishes the Jews usually there's
some other people coming in you know on
the seemed like the Assyrians or the
Babylonians with enrollment is and then
the Jews get their act together and then
God saves them again and so it's this
constant ebb and flow the Jews were
conquered by Babylon and Babylonians
really did a number on them they took
they took pretty much anybody who is
entered
yeah and said okay you're no longer
living here you're living in Babylon
they transported the entire inteligencia
the entire leadership and they just left
you know the ordinary people stuck on
the land with no leadership no resources
so it wasn't a good time for them so if
you could escape that it would make
sense why why you would do that how does
he escaped but he goes over to America
he crosses the Atlantic lands in the New
World and he and his family to get a new
life together his descendants divided
into two different tribes the Nephites
and the Lamanites and there they come in
contact with each other or conflict with
each other that stops for a while
because somebody shows up on seeing who
puts an end of the conflicts and here's
where it gets very distinctively
American Jesus shows up on the American
continent the resurrected Christ you
know what he's doing here is he's
providing a text that would fill in
parts of the story that Christians were
often speculated about so there's a
reign of peace for about 200 years then
there's an there's new conflict and
father the llama tanks destroy the
netflix more ami is the last surviving
Nephite and so he takes his history from
his father on these golden tablets hides
it in the hill and then that's it for
him until Joseph Smith turns up on the
scene much later the the llama nights
lose track of their history and who
would they become who's here when the
European show up and say I would
discover this place yeah exactly in the
Mormon way of looking at things the
Native Americans are actually the
descendants of this loft group of Jews
they forgotten their their history they
forgot their origins and so Native
Americans have
particular significance for the latter
day sighs so your book talks about if
you actually read the book of Mormon
which which is an interesting read
written in a very King James II kind of
language which takes a little bit to get
past but if you if you can do that you
find out that most of the controversies
blessing of that were discussed in the
burned-over district that were being
hotly debated at that time get resolved
and your book gives you some some
examples Calvinists versus Armenian
theology distrust of secret societies
all these sorts of things so your book
also talks about this is a reopening of
the camp the Canon of Scripture what
counts as religious revelation and
Joseph Smith is going to later on add
more to this there's going to be the
Doctrine and Covenants there's going to
be another text called the pearl of
great price and they're all going to
arrive on the scene through new
revelations so this is a pretty
revolutionary idea that you would have
an ongoing sequence of revelation that
the Bible is just sort of the first step
in this I mean we're what other
religions do you see that sort of
attitude towards the Bible in terms of
Revelation there's an older older than
latter-day saints at least older
religion where that's the case come to
mind for anybody we give any hint be
called Christians peoples of the book
yeah yeah Muhammad was making a similar
claim no Joseph Smith is not being
influenced by Muhammad was really no
significant Muslim presence in America
at that time but it's the same sort of
idea that the Bible was a good start and
now you
have additional revelations that are
going to filling in some of the gaps and
so Smith begins this is this new church
yeah it says Smith's new Church of Jesus
Christ had been divinely established in
last days its preparation for the second
coming of Jesus is there self
understanding this is the way in which
they make sense out of their own mission
and you see these restorations taking
place he Institute's of Twelve Apostles
the the Church of Jesus Christ of
latter-day saints still has 12 people
who are appointed as apostles that's
part of their structure later on they
reconstitute the Melchizedek Priesthood
well kiss attack was a priest back in
the Old Testament who Abraham runs into
and has some some sombrero that turns
out to be an important notion he
introduces a number of new ordinances
and ordinances are religious rituals
that are regarded as you know some way
initiating you or continuing the life
that you're supposed to lead now there's
a whole history or sort of sort of a
travel itinerary involved in this so he
starts out in marker starts out in their
new york and they don't stay there that
look they they leave for Kirtland Ohio
which is near Cleveland so they're
moving which direction moving west right
this is part of the westward expansion
in America and see how it plays an
extremely important role in America and
colonization of the continent he and he
bring us as Conrad salon there there was
this guy Sidney Rigdon who sort of
repairs the way Sidney Sidney Rigdon
starts out in one of the other groups
that we studied just another chapter the
restoration us and he converts and
becomes part of Joseph Smith's church
and at Kirtland they started to create a
contributes a planned community a
community that's structured around the
church they build their first temple
temples are going to assume an important
role as a sort of central place so the
first Mormon temple is in Kirtland and
they come up with a few new additions to
their view revelations the patriarchal
blessing which you know we want to talk
that much about but polygamy begins to
emerge at this point at that time it's
under wraps there some of them are
practicing it and it's not publicly
known the way it's going to do they are
on now they're not able to stay there
forever they also begin is this communal
property ownership the United order you
know that didn't last that long but it
was kind of a sign of where they were at
the beginning they started aunty banking
society some of you may be familiar with
modern-day movements that are sort of
like this people don't want to put their
trust in banks what do people usually
have against banks this is actually
something sort of worth thinking about
how would it be the bank account where
after that oh all right what don't you
like about your bank needs fees what
else
are you making any money on your money
are they making money on your money yes
now you know you don't have to worry
about like losing your deposit because
it's your your badge probably
fdic-insured later on when you start
having like retirement accounts and
things like that then you gotta start
getting more you know when stock market
crashes there goes all that money when
we had to crash in 2008 there was wealth
that existed on paper that never really
existed in real life and it all
disappeared if you can keep local
control if you can add your own currency
if you can you know barter and trade
that's a little bit more tangible right
it feels safer the banks at the time
we're not particularly delighted plus
they have all sorts of problems and
issues that would come up they were not
FDIC I thought you know insured at that
time so Smith you know it's doing
something that other people have done
starts as this anti banking society in
an issued currency engaged in other
financial activities and then it
collapsed sort of like you know how
people are doing all this stuff of
Bitcoin these days are you following
that and if you have if I ask who's got
Bitcoin ER who doesn't or the Bitcoin
clones there's number of them out there
it's a matter of fact the Lakota
reservation right now is actually
talking about the Lakota tribe sorry are
talking about issuing their own currency
it's all its hotly debated issue right
now whether they should do their own
Bitcoin if you do that and everything
goes great you're fine if you do that
and the currency collapses it becomes
very difficult to carry out transactions
doesn't it because nobody will accept
your currency so they one way to deal
with that at least you could do this
back there go somewhere else and here's
where they end up settling in Missouri
Illinois eventually creating a town
called Abu now move such a bad speller
they try to snoop supplement that far
west Missouri then they go back to
commerce Illinois which is on the
Mississippi they change the city's name
to know who he and they killed another
temple and this is where Joseph Smith is
going to meet his end because by this
time they're actually becoming quite
powerful they have a very systematic way
of life that's based on these these
revelations that not everybody else
believes in agrees with and you know one
of the temptations is of imposing your
own order on somebody else so they start
doing that some of the local people and
that's going to eventually alienate the
population they already seem a bit odd
to everybody else and eventually this is
going to culminate in Smith being being
perceived as a dictator the governor
orders Smith to surrender himself to
face charges Smith goes to the jail and
what happens to them in the jail
sometimes jails were the safest place to
be in ancient in and not ancient but in
19th century America you put somebody in
jail precisely to keep other people from
killing them a mom surrounds the jail
breaks in and they in effect lynch it so
now what does that do there's two ways
this could go so if you've got a
movement and one of the leaders of the
movement is killed the movement could
dr. Wright doesn't that happen what's
what's the alternative to that but the
movement doesn't die what happens to
that leader yeah
yeah now that were murdered what does
that mean it goes back to ancient
Christian times who are the martyrs Fox
wrote a book later about the Puritan
martyrs who got burned up by the
Catholics or the Anglican most of the
Catholics what makes you a murder yeah
exactly literally means witness so it's
not like witness like to show off you
know because you got subpoena and you
get your testimony and then get out and
then have night you know nice dinner or
something like that rather you're
witnessing is something that you believe
in so much that you're willing to die
for it and oftentimes you do have a
dashboard that's the way Smith who
already looked at as a prophet he comes
for latter-day saints a martyr there's a
few other things to mention before we
let go into the succession stuff one of
the we're going to look at a lot of
Mormon doctrine and beliefs and
practices in a later chapter but there's
one that I want to mention right here
because your book friends enough and
that's happening at Google and that's
the baptism to the debt how many verted
this before because i know there's quite
a bit of information about latter-day
saints something nobody this is why
genealogy is so important to the
latter-day saints this is why you know
they made major contributions to
websites dealing with genealogy in the
early days of the internet they may
actually provide a big public service by
doing this um here's the basic idea
Joseph Smith is coming on the scene he's
got this revelation this is something
that was not available to people before
his time so in order to get to heaven
you you know you have to not only behave
the right way you have to have the right
leaves you have to have the right faith
and things if you couldn't hear the the
right message before you're kind of
screwed aren't you that's unfair
is it be sort of like like in this class
right I give you the syllabus the the
last week of class and they say well
some of you have been doing it quite
well in this class you've been doing all
these these things and all counties as
assignments some of you are doing
terrible and then he'd say dr. Sandler
that's not really fair you know you're
supposed to actually give us the
syllabus at the beginning so we know
what's what's happening the whole
semester well you know I'm the the
professor I get to decide these things I
do as I choose that would be sort of
like you know the capricious conception
of God where you know people don't know
the rules but they're still being judged
by them so the baptism for the dead and
what i'm doing here is really just an
analogy i'm not saying this actually is
mormon doctrine you know presented well
but what they're doing is they're your
friends trying to right the wrong try to
fix the balance so if I for example
let's say I'm an active Joseph Smith's
time I had at least two parents
gentlemen just two right although you
know I actually have a mom and dad and
birth mom and somewhere out there birth
dad so I've actually got get four cuz I
was a doctor and I would care about
these people now if i was living back in
the 1830s 40s 50s and my parents had
died a long time ago they wouldn't have
had the opportunity to participate in
this what if i could do something for
them that would would set that straight
what if i could get baptized for them
and then a lot of them the chance to get
in on the new faith that's what this
notion of baptism for the dead kingdom
that's why genealogy was so important
because they know everybody knows who
their mom and dad is more or less some
people don't right i don't actually know
my birth father's i suppose i could but
it's it's a more matter of choice
there's a whole story there but most
people don't wear pants are entered
and parents and maybe the
great-grandparents doesn't think it kind
of hazy after that now if you could
actually do this great thing for them
wouldn't you want to figure out who
these people are so you could in fact
carry out this this work of salvation
for them that's why the interest in
genealogy became so so acute so that's
that's part of this story now like I
imagined Joseph Smith dies here this
isn't the end of the morbid story where
do they go after this some of them to
actually stayed in Missouri area the
reorganized Church of latter-day saints
which becomes a community of christ they
stay in the area they have their own
temple but the majority of them go where
we're Mormon still a major presence
today Utah exactly now Ohio New York was
very ill on going over States at this
time utah is just this massive
unincorporated territory still inhabited
by Native Americans the parts of it that
are habitable to some of this just
desert and it's not just desert at Salt
desert something which you know it's
tough to have to do things but most of
them go out to Utah under this guy
Brigham Young he's another major player
in this this story there's a university
out there named after right brigham
young university why because he's the
one who let the trek out there and they
come out to the Great Salt Lake they
declare a provisional state of Deseret
which means honey bee and this
provisional state gets recognized by the
governor but the government is Utah
Territory Brigham Young is the first
governor of that territory so what
you've got in Utah originally is what we
call a theocracy if the religious
authorities who are actually running the
the government and the entire state is
organized around religious authority the
book points out just a few features of
this they have this cooperative
economics scheme which involve massive
irrigation projects if any of you are
from a rural background you know you
lived around drainage ditches they fill
in pretty quickly and it takes a lot of
work to actually keep them open even
with tractors imagine doing that by hand
with shovels that's what it required so
it took a lot of manpower and it took a
lot of coordination one of the
advantages of having an organization
like this is you can do that sort of
thing they literally made the Desert
Bloom they colonized Utah they actually
colonize parts of adjoining states
there's a lot of latter-day saints in
Idaho and Arizona in other parts of
border Utah Nevada and they built a
temple a new temple a massive edifice
which is quite a wait of sight they they
built a new society out there and your
book sort of leaves off at this point
what's going to happen after this the
other parts of the story are you know is
America usually too happy with theocracy
and we've talked about a lot of themes
that title the disestablishment remember
disestablishment and fiat receive those
are not going to go in these guys are
already pretty different from other
Protestant Christians our other
Protestant Christian is going to be okay
with with this group actually running an
entire state not for long but we're
going to leave that part of the story
for later on and we talk about
in a bit more detail